do you think it's true that women will
make rules for the wrong guy but break
rules for the right guy I do I do
believe that
I think so too well I mean sometimes you
like the bad boys so we tend to break
the rules for them do you think that
women tend to lust after bad boys but
want to settle down with nice guys oh we
sure do I love a bad boy what's
attractive about a bad boy they just
have that quality that just is so
attractive how do bad boys treat women
horrible so then what why would you want
to be with a bad boy when they treat you
badly because they do other things that
the good ones don't like what I don't
want to go there
we know we know they do why do you think
women don't pick the nice guys
I mean it's more of a thrill I would
imagine I mean
you know I get it that you know and it's
I understand to some degree that like a
guy who's very indecisive and you know
you want someone who can kind of show
that take charge mentality
um so if you're indecisive like I I
don't know where should we go out like I
get that gets frustrating but you also
have to understand if you're asking for
the guy who really listens to you he
wants to know your opinion that's
actually what he's saying he says I want
to I want to listen to you I want to
hear what you're saying I wanna
appreciate what you want out of this
relationship and I'll then take action
but women kind of more so want I want
you just make the decision tell me what
to do and then go with it and run with
it from there
and
so it's kind of like Miss like
miscommunicated signals where they're
asking for one thing and getting another
and but even when they get it they're
not quite pleased with it and yeah to
put it put it simply it's a bit of a
clusterfucker do you think that men are
[ __ ] because women date [ __ ] yeah
so then do you think women have the
right to complain when they're enabling
that behavior no uh and like speaking
truthfully like I think back to one of
my earliest girlfriends where I was
definitely too much of a nice guy and I
got walked all over and I can tell you
from experience I changed my behavior to
be more of an [ __ ] simply for that
point in that I was like I don't want
this to happen again
it's like men and women are different
it's like it's okay because the world
doesn't care if you do what's easy it's
easy for us to get sex it's hard for men
to get sex so it's like if you do the
easy thing everyone's like okay
who do you think is more likely to be
able to have sex without feelings men or
women
well if it's if it's not as hard that's
hard because it's just like yeah like
some females they be out here they can
just have sex with a man for money and
they just be that
and a man could just you know he could
like what he could he just like what he
see
well I mean if it's not women why do the
majority of sex workers happen to be
women
ah
I'm ah oh can you repeat that would you
say that bad boys do you look at them as
more of protectors
um
they are protectors I do feel like you
know I found more Security in the bad
ones but I also feel like I got used by
more of the bad ones than I did being
um protected So speaking of being a
protector if women expect men to pay for
sex why don't men expect women to pay
for bodyguards uh because they're stupid
why do women often describe men as
stupid but then expect love from them in
return
um why do we describing that stupid
because we've been through a lot of
stuff so because but isn't it fair to
say a lot of men have been through a lot
of stuff as well they have but I feel
like you know sometimes you get a good
woman and you treat her like [ __ ] and
then you expect us to not call you
stupid when you do us dirty and then
we're standing there looking stupid but
yet you are the stupid ones because
guess what they always come back and I
can say that for prime example every one
of them have come back
that when don't you think that's just
like batting out of your league though
like you get [ __ ] treatment because
you're shooting too high
um I don't think I'm shooting too high I
don't I don't know you but just like in
general like if if you're you know if
you're shooting too high like they don't
treat you right you know what I mean
because that's a guy that's got a lot of
options and are we talking about the bad
boys yeah like usually bad boys have a
lot of options
they may have a lot of options but they
don't have a lot of good ones and I'm a
good one so therefore I'm gonna always
aim high because guess what the quality
is always going to be there
so I mean if you lose out then you're
the one who's stupid
wouldn't you say if you're a good one
like someone would have picked you I can
say if I was a good one they would have
picked me but still we always get
overlooked because sometimes being good
doesn't always mean that they want a
good girl they want somebody that's a
bad girl and when you're too good to
someone then they feel like you know
that's not what they want you feel like
they like take advantage they do take
advantage nowadays is the woman expects
that you are going to fill these rules
and if you're not she's kind of gonna
overtake those roles and it the men get
belittled they feel lower self-esteem
they're not as high valued as they want
to be and it's
it's kind of a juggling act so a man has
two women
one he
which one does he
he tough one uh
usually it's the one he's lying to why
is that
because he doesn't want to hurt her
feelings and
it's hot it's harder to be just bluntly
honest with a woman because you never
know what her reaction is going to be
so
if you're being bluntly honest with her
then you probably
you either respect her a hundred percent
or you don't really care how she's gonna
feel do you think uh women often want
what they can't have yes so then
wouldn't you say that chasing women is
terrible advice for men
chasing women because if he chases you
then he's basically telling you you can
have me and he's no longer a challenge I
like a Chase because I I always got my
running shoes on
so um yeah I do like a Chase do you
think uh do you think that men prefer
the chase or the catch
they prefer the chase because when
they're eat when you're easy to catch
they don't want you after they got you
so do you think women prefer men who
like to chase
I do I love a good Chase as I said I
always got them running shoes on but
wouldn't you say that men who prefer the
chase are less likely to be loyal
because they will continue chasing very
true because uh well once they actually
get you then they don't want you anymore
so
which sucks though but unless you get a
good guy who actually likes a woman that
kind of holds out and she's good quality
then the chase was worth it but we don't
like the good guys and you said before
like we make rules for them right so if
you're making a guy wait you probably
don't like him that much
it's for Bruno Mars you're down tomorrow
right most likely
how long would he really have to talk to
you Bruno yeah like if you said I want
sex like would you if Bruno started
singer Versace on the floor wouldn't
everything would happen I'd be butt
naked before he got to the first verse
he wouldn't even have the first V out
can I tell you an interesting stat that
I think most women don't know you know
one in three men under 30 are either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year oh I didn't know that so A lot of
times like we'll complain about guys
cheating but we picked the cheaters
because there's a lot of guys that won't
cheat on you we just don't like them I
honestly did not know that and that's a
good fact to know would you believe it
like does that make sense with what
you've seen I believe it but I still end
up with a cheater
because we like I think we like guys
that she was not having sex is somewhere
where I don't see because I'm going with
the bad boys
so yes so would you say that a lot of
women are more attracted to like toxic
men
um
yeah I I yeah I think they we are so why
do women complain about you know toxic
masculinity when a lot of women are
enabling that behavior by choosing to
date bad boys and toxic men I all think
I think it stems from our childhood
sometimes we have somebody in our life
that
is a toxic person because we've seen it
happen to someone else in our family as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible